today i'm gonna compare this festering
pile of crap the rx 6500 xt to an nvidia
quadro t600 and then once i realize that
that's actually a pretty terrible
comparison i'll compare it to something
else
[Music]
we will
oh it's such a cute little loser
graphics card thank you very much
gigabyte for sending it over for this
video that is some sparse video out
action now the main reason why i thought
it was a good idea to compare the very
warmly received rx 6500 xt to the quadro
t600 is because they're both in stock at
the moment for about the same amount of
money in all fairness on paper they do
seem comparable in that they're both
graphics cards and considering that
these are some of the few graphics cards
actually available at the moment i think
it's worth checking out how they stack
up
[Music]
oh it's so tiny
look at how little and cute that gpu die
is it's so small in fact that in
comparison the t600 die looks like it
subsists off a diet entirely of steroids
and horse tranquilizers and gigabyte
seems to use a thermal party to
interface with everything on the pcb
which does tear when you remove the
cooler and that means that you do have
to replace that if you want to repaste
your cooler you can actually see the
four pcie lanes coming off it which is
fascinating with that let's check out
the gaming performance of these two
unlikely combatants
[Music]
now just to set a quick baseline with
the t600 this is gta 5 running at 1080p
high settings and um it's it's running
very well we're
getting almost 120 frames per second
it it dips down to about the high 90s
every now and then all in all this is a
pretty good gaming experience it looks
nice it runs well the power draw is
actually very low so that quadro card
can go in some very small systems and
you don't need to worry about you know
your power supply being overburdened or
whatever so even a more demanding game
like battlefield 5 running at medium
settings at 1080p gives you a pretty
consistent 60ish frames per second on
this uh this quadro t600 i am very
curious to see how that rx 6500 xt is
gonna stack up here um because yeah this
is this is usable right this is a pretty
good gaming experience it's not amazing
but it's it's usable
[Music]
with that let's try out everyone's
favorite graphics card
[Music]
i love how even according to amd's
drivers this brand new graphics card
already needs to be upgraded that tells
you a lot about how amd feels about this
card and then i made a shocking
discovery the 6500 xt
doesn't have an encoder on it so it
can't screen capture what what is this
thing
what was amd thinking after taking the
necessary time to calm myself down after
this complete outrage i moved on to the
gaming i was ready for this to be much
worse than the d600 i'm not gonna lie
um but it is
it is already doing quite a bit better
in all fairness it does use almost
double the power and
it's got almost double its core
frequency so yeah i'd really hope that
it would be faster than the d600 to be
honest
oh
okay um now granted battlefield 5 does
love amd gpus
but
this is considerably better at 1080p
medium settings than the t600 uh so if
you really like battlefield 5 the the
6500 xt is actually a pretty solid bet
it seems
[Music]
now i was quite butthurt by the victory
of this encoderless loser so i decided
to take a gladius to the 6500 xt's
achilles heel for justice
on the surface this performance feels
relatively similar to how it felt before
this is gta 5 mind you this is quite an
old game uh so
it may be running fine because
it's not running into the bandwidth
limitation it's
maybe a little bit worse than it was
before but this is still a very playable
result so it's not not too bad it's
reasonably stuttery but you know that is
a battlefield 5
party trick now at this point i was
quite confused because i was under the
impression that going from pcie gen 4 to
gen 3 would be like amputating one of
the 6500 xt's legs but i honestly
couldn't tell the difference until i
tried doom eternal oh okay well
apparently going to pcie gen 3 does not
make a big difference to the performance
i guess it just depends on the game it
seems like some games go from running
fine to running like they've just had a
colonoscopy
[Music]
okay so clearly comparing the 6500 xt to
the t600 was a mistake and i probably
should have known that going in but i've
found a different comparison which may
make a bit more sense let's drop in this
rx 5300 which is like an unreleased amd
budget card from just over a year ago
and see how these two compare
[Music]
now you see this is a much better
comparison to the 6500 xt this graphics
card has a much smaller number for a
name and it seems to be performing quite
similarly although aside from numbers
which are maybe a bit smaller it does
have one massive advantage over the 6500
xt and it is that if i press ctrl shift
e
we get a recording happening
i cannot understand why the 6500 xt does
not have a video encoder in it but a rx
5300 does it it makes no sense to me
none at all
but yeah let's see what this graphics
card makes of a more demanding game this
is running about the same honestly is
the 6500 xt
uh give or take a couple frames per
second but this feels
basically the same and then you have the
advantage of this i know i keep talking
about it but it just annoys me that they
removed that feature from a graphics
card which
every graphics card that's been released
in the last five years has had without
question like
like come on amd what the hell
[Music]
so in conclusion it seems like what amd
should have done was just actually
launch the 5300 at its planned msrp of a
hundred and thirty dollars and they
would have won the world uh but they
didn't do that so they they didn't win
the world um maybe next time amd maybe
maybe you'll get him next time anyway
with that thank you for watching if you
enjoyed the video do consider
subscribing to the channel my mom
actually told me that she'll give me the
day off school tomorrow if i got 20 subs
off this video so you have the power to
make that happen and yeah anyway thank
you for watching bye
[Music]
uh